digamos que queremos evaluar esta
integral indefinida le echas un vistazo
rápido observas esta raíz de 4 menos x
al cuadrado y dices bueno intentemos
resolver esta integral utilizando una
sustitución pero lo intenta si no
funciona la sustitución realmente no
hace que esta expresión se simplifique y
entonces te quedas mirando fijamente y
dices bueno a ver esta raíz de 4 menos x
al cuadrado me recuerda al teorema de
pitágoras aunque te recuerda por ejemplo
a un triángulo rectángulo que tiene una
hipotenusa de tamaño 2 y esta expresión
sería lo que obtendríamos si uno de los
lados uno de los catetos fuera equis y
quisiéramos encontrar el otro cateto
aunque porque entonces para encontrar la
longitud del otro cateto tendríamos la
hipotenusa al cuadrado o sea 2 al
cuadrado - el otro cateto al cuadrado o
sea x al cuadrado y tomamos la raíz d
según el teorema de pitágoras entonces
pues vamos a explorar un poco más a
fondo esa idea así es que tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo por aquí
y si por alguna razón esto no te recordó
al teorema de pitágoras no hay ningún
problema la verdad es muy probable que
la primera vez que yo vi esta expresión
tampoco me haya acordado del teorema de
pitágoras pero es una muy buena forma de
recordarlo
así es que digamos que tenemos este
triángulo rectángulo y vamos a ver
claramente todo eso que estábamos
diciendo acerca de esta raíz entonces si
la hipotenusa de este triángulo
rectángulo es 2 que ésta es la
hipotenusa del triángulo rectángulo la
hipotenusa mide 2 y si este lado de aquí
este cateto de aquí tiene una longitud x
que lo sé es un poco contraintuitivo que
este cateto sea el cateto x porque
generalmente esta dirección y estos
lados los asociamos con ye y estos lados
los asociamos con x pero para no hacer
un relajo en la pantalla vamos a decir
que este lado es el que mide x
pero bueno si esta es la hipotenusa y
este cateto mide x entonces cuánto mide
este otro lado de aquí y cuánto mide
este lado de aquí pues si utilizamos el
teorema de pitágoras la longitud de este
cateto es la raíz de la hipotenusa al
cuadrado pero 2 al cuadrado es
simplemente 4 - la longitud del otro
cateto al cuadrado aunque ello sea menos
x al cuadrado y eso está súper curioso
no está súper interesante y es justo lo
que estábamos diciendo hace unos cuantos
minutos ahora aunque esté muy
interesante eso como nos sirve como nos
ayuda a resolver esta integral y justo
en ese punto es donde entra la
trigonometría porque si tomamos este
ángulo y le llamamos theta entonces
cuáles son seno de teta y coseno de teta
en términos de los lados de este
pues el seno de nube zeta
cateto puesto sobre hipotenusa ok
entonces es x entre 2 ahora si queremos
despejar la x lo que nos queda es que x
es igual a 2 por el seno detecta bueno
pero que hay del coste no beteta coseno
de teta es igual al cateto adyacente
entre la hipotenusa aunque yo sea
de 4 - x al cuadrado entre 2 o si
queremos despejar este lado del
triángulo entonces lo que nos queda es
que la raíz de 4 - x al cuadrado es
igual a 2 por el coste no de teta y eso
está súper interesante porque si x es
igualados por el seno beteta entonces
toda esta expresión se simplifica a 2
coseno de teta y eso como vas a ver en
unos momentos es más interesante de lo
que te imaginas entonces vamos a hacer
la sustitución x igual a 2 x seno de
teta y si x es igualados por seno de
teta entonces de x es igual a 2 por
coseno de teta de teta
y bueno si x es igual a 1290 entonces
esta cosa de aquí como acabamos de ver
es igual a dos cosas
beteta ok esto de aquí es igual a 2
coseno beteta
hicimos todo esto imaginándonos este
triángulo rectángulo y luego utilizamos
las definiciones de seno y de coseno
pero de cualquier forma si en algún
momento decidió hacer esta sustitución
la consecuencia inmediata es que la raíz
de 4 - x cuadrada tiene que ser
igualados por coseno de teta hockey y
para llegar a eso simplemente sustituye
es el 2% o beteta aquí en esta x y
utilizas algunas identidades
trigonométricas y listo te queda 2 x
coseno beteta pero bueno eso no lo vamos
a hacer por el momento más bien vamos a
saltarnos lo íbamos a seguir con esta
integral que está súper padre porque ahí
tenemos está integral y este 1 de x lo
tenemos por aquí de x es 2 por coseno de
teta de teta
entonces vamos a ponerlo por aquí dos
coseno detecta de teta y esta raíz de 4
- x cuadraban es otra vez 2 por coseno
de teta aunque 2 por coseno de teta y
esto está súper padre porque esto es
simplemente un 1 y entonces toda la
integral se simplifica a de teta que si
lo evaluamos en este intervalo
indefinido éste está más una constante y
pues esto está bastante padre pero pues
teníamos aquí una integral en términos
de x y nos gustaría obtener un resultado
en términos de x y no en términos de
esta teta que pues la verdad otras
personas no saben a qué nos referimos
contenta si no ven todo lo que hicimos
por aquí
no hay ningún problema porque podemos
escribir a teta en términos de x-trade
tenemos que x es igual a dos porsche no
vete te vamos a escribirlo por aquí otra
vez x es igual a 2 por seno de teta
dividimos entre 2 y obtenemos que x
entre 2 es igual a seno detecta recuerda
que ahora lo que queremos despejar este
está y esto nos está diciendo que teta
es el ángulo al cual si lo evalúa sense
no te queda x entre 2 entonces podríamos
decir que teta es la función inversa de
seno
se no función inversa evaluada en x
entre 2 evaluada en x entre 2 pero esta
función inversa de seno tiene su nombre
arco seno y la queremos evaluar en x
entre 2 para obtener theta así es que
esta integral de aquí es igual teta es
igual a
arco xenón
de equis entre dos más una constante y
listo ya terminamos acabamos de evaluar
a esta integral indefinida ahora por
aquí hay algunos detalles de los que tal
vez te diste cuenta tal vez no pero hace
muy rápido por aquí para no perder el
hilo de la idea pero hay algunos
detalles muy interesantes a los cuales
les tenemos que prestar atención aquí el
dominio de x está restringido y sería
una excelente idea ver paso por paso qué
pasa con el dominio de x cuando hacemos
esta sustitución para estar seguros de
que no estamos haciendo nada extraño
porque entonces vamos a verlo aquí el
dominio de xy vamos a ponerlo por aquí x
tiene que ser mayor que menos 2 y menor
que 2 porque si el valor absoluto de x
fuera exactamente igual a 2 2 al
cuadrado es 4 y aquí tendríamos un cero
en el denominador que no puede suceder
ok no podemos dividir entre 0
y si el valor absoluto de x fuera más
grande que 2 entonces estaríamos sacando
la raíz de un número negativo osea
tendríamos un número imaginario y
tampoco podemos hacer estas integrales
entonces esto de aquí es nuestro dominio
y queremos ver que esta sustitución no
hace cosas extrañas con este dominio
aunque tenemos que x está entre menos
dos y dos y x es igual a dos por seno de
teta eso lo que significa es que dos
porsche no detectan tiene que estar
entre dos y menos dos y bueno aquí
tenemos muchos dos podríamos dividir
todo entre dos y lo que nos queda es que
un menos uno es menor que seno
z lo cual tiene que ser menor que 1 y
para que eso suceda podemos decir que
teta es menor que pi sobre 2 y mayor que
menos pi sobre 2 si ésta cumple con
estas desigualdades
entonces seno de teta también y por lo
tanto x también ok senodep y medios es 1
seno de menos y medios es menos 1 y
entonces estamos restringiendo el
dominio detecta y de x de una forma muy
razonable y además funciona súper bien
porque el dominio de la función arco
seno es justo este de aquí de menos y
medios up y medios así es que por lo
menos con respecto a ese detalle nos
podemos sentir muy bien ahora otro
detalle por aquí estamos dividiendo
entre dos coseno beteta y eso no tiene
ningún problema a menos de que cose no
detecta sea igual a cero en algún punto
de nuestro dominio porque no podemos
dividir entre
pero lo bueno es que mientras theta sea
mayor que menos pi medios y menor que
prime dios coseno detecta va a ser
distinto de cero lo que hay de hecho va
a ser positivo si admitiéramos pi medios
o menos pi medios dentro del dominio
entonces coseno de teta si sería igual a
cero y tendríamos que pensar en alguna
otra forma de restringir el dominio pero
no los estamos agregando en el dominio
así es que todo parece estar súper bien
entonces teníamos aquí una integral
encontramos una substitución muy
conveniente y llegamos a esta respuesta
y luego nos fijamos en estos detalles
que surgieron pero todo está muy bien
con estos detalles así es que nos
podemos sentir bastante bien con esta
respuesta